on est dans le détail
levez les têtes sur les 200 derniers
mètres le bicorne par la bonne direction
le sourire ce matin à satori c'est le
débrief en vue de la fête nationale du
14 juillet
puis de 280 étudiants volontaires de
Polytechnique sont invités à défiler aux
Champs-Élysées
en voiture et vérifier que tout le monde
soit bien et ensuite on va se décaler et
passer de l'autre côté pour défiler et
pour justement faire la deuxième
répétition de la journée
comme si on était sur les Champs-Élysées
mais cette fois-ci asatori sur 800
mètres cet étudiant n'aurait peut-être
pas pu assister à cet événement s'il
n'avait pas intégré l'école
polytechnique l'année dernière à une
semaine des résultats parcoursup il
change d'avis et oriente ses choix vers
des classes préparatoires aux grandes
écoles si comme moi vous tout départ
vous êtes un peu hésitant sur ce que
vous allez faire plus tard au niveau
étude n'hésitez vraiment pas à choisir
la prépa surtout si vous avez l'envie si
vous avez les capacités si vos
professeurs vous le conseillent vraiment
faites-le parce que personnellement j'ai
failli passer à côté et là le fait
d'avoir d'y avoir été je regrette pas du
tout j'ai choisi la prépa Hoche à
Versailles j'ai eu la chance justement
après les concours d'intégrer
Polytechnique aujourd'hui Mathéo a déjà
en poche un stage en gendarmerie
nationale et souhaite explorer d'autres
métiers pour son professeur et capitaine
Henri Benoît Lefrançois c'est un élève
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme il a
beaucoup de facilités parce qu'il est
très volontaire très dynamique vraiment
à l'écoute et qui c'est vraiment très
vite intégré au sein à la fois de sa
section et de sa compagnie qu'il a
vraiment bien pris le rythme de la
promotion au niveau aussi bien
académique que sportif
[Musique]
c'est bien passé dans notre colonne donc
c'est vraiment bien aligné alors c'était
la force la meilleure répétition au
niveau d'alignement dans les colonnes
c'est déjà un bon une bonne première
impression vendredi sera un grand jour
pour Mathéo et ses camarades ils seront
parmi les 6500 participants au défilé
comme chaque année les polytechniciens
ouvriront la marge des écoles militaires
une tradition qui se fait depuis 136 ans
[Musique]